[Musique]
c'est à l'école primaire du centre à
saint philippe que olivier rivière maire
de la commune et cyrille melchior
président du département signent le
pacte de solidarité territoriale
un dispositif dead qui vise à renforcer
l'unité et la solidarité du département
envers les communes j'ai chargé le vice
président monsieur alarmant à mes côtés
de travailler sur ce pst parce que cette
unité cette solidarité cette exprimer
pleinement dans ce pacte de solidarité
90 millions d'euros 75 millions en
investissement 15 millions en
fonctionnement la commune de
saint-philippe disposera d'une enveloppe
de plus de 2 millions d'euros affectés
aux projets d'investissement et de 281
7000 euros pour les actions sociales
notamment pour l'insertion des jeunes et
la mise en place de portage de repas à
domicile pour les personnes dépendantes
parce que je sais que c'est lui ce qui
est très attendu en fait par le
président du département s'est ensuite
rendu à sainte rose où il s'est
entretenu avec le maire de la commune
michel vergoz
ensemble ils signent à leur tour le
pacte de solidarité territoriale au sein
de cette petite commune de moins de
10000 habitants
le président du département a voulu
rappeler le caractère équitable de ce
dispositif envers les 24 communes de
l'île
ces deux diagonales à tout le monde un
montant minimal des millions d'euros à
chaque commune et après bien sûr on a
tenu compte de la population c'est sale
et quitter une répartition pour chacun
se retrouve avec plus de deux millions
deux cent mille euros dead en
investissement la commune portera les
projets d'aménagement et d'ouverture du
territoire pour les visiteurs les
investissements que nous allions
réaliser avec eux cette enveloppe va
aller nous permettre de de renforcer
notre la conceptualisation et la
réalisation de notre boucle du centre
de notre centre-ville demain avec ce
plateau synthétique qui viendra
s'intégrer au tour de l'éclat autour de
la réhabilitation de la mairie autour de
la halle et 800 mètres de là du paradis
de la façade maritime du port
[Musique]